welcome to simply learn data structures
in our my name is Orion stalard and I
appreciate you joining us today
we're going to just take a quick look
through some of the high-level aspects
of our programming if you're new to our
it's a very powerful and easy to use
programming language it's been around
since 1993 and it's grown in popularity
to what we would argue is the is really
the top data science programming
language in the world it's open source
so it's free originally it came out from
the University of Auckland two
professors launched it to help their
students and it got so popular that they
decided to continue the work as an open
source programming language it's been
revised multiple times and it's now a
popular choice with businesses with
educational universities and
institutions of all walks throughout the
world so again if you're just starting
our or you're just trying to figure out
what it is this is a really good time in
place for you to be here if you have a
background in computer science then stay
with me we're gonna do a quick
high-level on this and it should refresh
you and remind you of things that you
already know in the language that you
started started with whether that's
Python or whether for instance if you're
in C or Java there are going to be
common elements across all languages
hence R is a turing-complete language so
these are the are the things that we're
going to hit on in this lesson again
this is just a quick summary to get you
familiar with the data structures so
that you can launch whatever application
you would like to quickly and I don't
say effortlessly but with a little bit
of thought preparation and planning
you'll be well on your way to using this
tool
as soon as you'd like and in the fact
that it's free our that is compared with
many other competitors makes it that
much more of an accessible tool that you
can actually use really right now at the
end of this lesson so explaining the
different data structures discussing the
elements of the data structures and the
acceptable formats for import and export
is the goal of this lesson it's brought
to you by simply learn and our purpose
here is to help you excel and and reach
your goals using our programming so as
you can see here there are five types of
data structures in our and in kind of
order of complexity is the way that
we've we've arranged them here vectors
are the simplest vectors are of course
one-dimensional as you can see in the
picture we've Illustrated that with
these three blocks but a vector in
essence is going to be all data types
that are the same such as a numeric a
character like a string you may call it
a logical true/false any of those data
types factors are going to be of the
same type if they are contained within a
vector in other words you don't have
logical and numeric or factors and
numeric within contained within a vector
a matrix is a vector that has been
expanded into a grid so you now have a
two dimensional format similar to a
table and the same is true with a matrix
that is true with a vector in fact you
could look at a matrix and consider to
be a group of vectors that have been
joined or appended together an array
it's dimensionality tube matrices so
arrays can expand matrices and if you
have a computer programming or database
background if you are familiar with or
if you've ever heard of the online
analytical processing cube this array
would be a good analogy to an OLAP u
data frames are by far the most commonly
used data structure in R and the reason
is because data frames now are the first
place that we can combined elements of
different types and so that would be the
same that you may be familiar with if
you've been accustomed to using
workbooks in Excel if you are putting
data into columns that have different
data types such as your best friend's
name the birthday their favorite color
whether they're a boy or a girl if
they're over 21 you know different
things like that contained within a data
frame and carrying that a step further
all of these that we've just discussed
can be contained within a list so a list
is actually the most complex data
structure in our and as we just talked
about vectors are one-dimensional arrays
and these are examples that you can use
you can use these in your own life
whether that's in your business in your
education if you're a student right now
if you're a professor at a university
and you want to keep track of students
any of those be easy places that you
could organize a vector you could put a
vector of your students for instance
together as we see here B gets C and C
stands for combined or concatenate these
elements or in this case these are like
strings or factors one two
you three notice and it's important that
we that we spell out the fact that when
we want to identify a a factor that it
is both contained within parentheses and
quotation marks in R and R is also case
sensitive so that's important to point
out logical is true and false you can
see that we have a vector that where
we're identifying here so this would be
a single vector true true true false
true false a is numeric B his character
C is logical these are one scalars are
one element vectors that you would use
for constant value something that you're
going to continue to refer back to in
are scalars unlike some languages start
with the value one so in this case for
instance F gets three anytime we print F
three is going to is going to follow so
a colon is a way to use a little
shorthand notation and these are just a
few kind of sidebar things that are
important to be aware of that we're
going into here but it's just good to
know that in the expanded format for
instance with numerical you can you can
use commas and you can put up you know
one to a bazillion numbers here or I
could simply start with the first a
colon and followed by the last number so
in this case a gets 1 through 5 if I
print a it's gonna print out 1 2 3 4 5
the same thing is going to be the case
here there's just a lot less typing in
the first example so accessing vector
elements the the brackets give you a
convenient way to pull elements out of
your vectors and that would be very
handy for instance if you
are starting a business and it's the
next uber or the next you know Google
and you need to to kind of zoom in on
the customers that pay you the most and
you've developed an algorithm for doing
so and you know it's every other
customer for instance then you can use
this command vector combined and then
within the square brackets you can then
say combined and within the curve
brackets 2 comma 4 and you can continue
those 2 comma 4 comma 6 comma 8 and what
that will do is it will take and return
in this case the second and fourth and
if you said sixth here would return that
so here that one is going to return the
letter A the first element in the vector
so the when we identify a variable and
we assign a vector to that variable then
the square brackets allow us to quickly
pull elements data elements from the
vector so that's a nice little way to
quickly look at your data in arm
matrices as we talked about or
two-dimensional data structures they're
pretty much vectors that have been
combined together and you'll see how
that works in this command so vector 1
through 4 again we've expanded it out
instead of using a colon and then what
we do is we take another variable which
we call foo and we can actually call it
anything you could call a calculator you
could call it x1 but this is the
assignment that variable that we're
using and we're saying foo gets and
we're now using this function matrix and
matrix is now using what we previously
defined as a vector and it is within the
function putting it into the number of
rows of 2
number of columns of two so it's taking
this vector one two three four and it's
making it into a 2x2 grid again the
elements of the matrix have to be the
same type so if you had one through four
it's all got to be a numeric if you had
Sally Jim Bob and Joe it's all names if
you have true false false true it's all
boolean but it cannot be a combination
of those for it to be within a matrix
this is a little optional parameter that
some people like it allows you by row by
row allows you to pretty much
interchange the configuration of the
matrix from you know a column to a to a
row format some people use by row and
and enjoy using it that way when you
want to pull data from your matrix like
we did with vectors earlier this is the
command and it works the same as it did
with the vector you have a square
bracket and on within the square bracket
you you have a comma on the left side of
a comma is going to refer to the the
number refers to the rows and on the
right side of the comma refers to the
columns so if I want to get Row one
column to an element that's in that
position then I say Matt square bracket
1 column 1 comma 2 and that will give me
the data element that is in the first
row of the second column Matt of course
is short for matrix and the square
brackets is telling are that you're
retrieving information from your data
structure whether that be a vector or a
matrix the same holds true with an array
and with an array of course we have more
than two dimensions so we
have to specify within the number of
dimensions of the array exactly the row
and column so you know in this case what
we're doing is we're setting up an array
of numbers and we're calling it variable
a gets this matrix and then what we do
is we actually we identify the number of
dimensions that would represent the Rose
followed by the columns and in this case
we we can then take a and B which are
two matrices that we've just created and
we combined them together into our array
which we again we've named it
arbitrarily foo and that is the way that
you can you can begin to experiment with
arrays of that sum if that's a data
structure that that would be conducive
to your business model or to the type of
work that you're interested in and the
same as the way that we were able to
access data with the matrix is how they
raise work again with the square
brackets and the number that you of the
row or the column in arrays we refer to
them as dimensions so foo 2 comma comma
is going to get the first the second all
the elements in the second dimension
that's this case here 2 comma comma so
what why is it all of the elements
because we've left to the right side of
these two commas we've left blank in
this case 2 comma 1 comma is going to
give you the first row element in the
second dimension
but as you can see we also left the last
space here blank so that's a good way
for you to to look at dimensions the
number of dimensions that you create
within your arrays and to begin to
retrieve data using using the square
brackets within an array data frames as
we talked about earlier are really the
most popular data structure in our
because you can now use the data frame
to combine different data types so
numbers characters logicals they all are
fair game and play in the data frame so
in this case what have we done we've
taken three vectors named sex and age
are going to be the the column names in
effect so in this case we're combining
Joe John and Nancy sex is our male male
female and ages are numeric 27 26 26 and
we've now created Phu is our data frame
which combines the three vectors named
sex and age and as you'll see if we want
to pull data from any of those vectors
within our frame it's very simple just
like if you're using another program
that's got a tabular format such as
Excel
you've got columns and you've got
headings these would be the column
headings name age and by just running
the command foo name of our data frame
dollar sign age we're gonna get
everything that's within the age vector
of our data frame and you can see the
nice thing you know making the
comparison with excel again is that r is
free and our can handle a lot more data
than Excel can Excel kind of chokes at
around a million
Plus lines arose where our can get into
really hundreds of billions of rows so
when your dataset grows beyond the
capability of something such as as an
excel type product this becomes a really
quick easy convenient option for you
okay so these are going to be
categorical variables which are factors
and of course we're giving you some
examples gender status so on you can see
again that the factors are require that
we have curved brackets as well as
parentheses as well as quotation marks
around our string variables or elements
within our in order to tell our that
that's what you're doing so in this case
we've got gender status and what we're
doing is we're we're looking in saying
factor status gets and oh one thing
that's important too that I haven't
mentioned yet is the number sign
followed by a string of characters is
how you notate your code in R and it's
important to know that you can only do
that one line at a time it's not like
you can write you know a whole paragraph
with that number sign but the number
sign and the code notation of course is
considered good form for anybody who
comes behind you that's looking to
follow your code
list says we talked about it the most
complex data structures in our because
lists can combine any variation of
arrays matrices vectors you name it and
in fact other lists and so lists have
the potential to get out of hand but if
used properly it can be a very effective
tool in this case what we've done is
we've taken a vector one through four
and a matrix two by two and we've said
let's take foo and make vector or Veck
and Matt into a list and that's what
you're looking at there so the remainder
of this little talk about are that's
really just designed to give you a taste
and get your feet wet and and work your
appetite up for launching your your
career into our the remainder is really
about importing and exporting data and
the file types that you can use and what
works best so to start these are the
four you're looking at Excel Minitab
tables like text and CSV are the four
file types that you can import into our
and a couple things that are important
for you to know and we've notated it
here is when you're loading data into
our everything in our is done in
packages so the beginning load G data
package is what you see here library is
effectively what tells you if you have a
package installed in your in arm and so
library G data is actually loading the
package that you're going to that you're
going to use for your for your data set
help is a is a good command to you know
to be able to understand any function in
R so keep the help-help function itself
handy
and in this case what we're doing is
we're saying my data equals read XLS and
this is reading from the first sheet of
our excel file that we have in a in a
file path in this example the second
example here we're loading a different
package but affecting the same thing and
load workbook my data dot XLS
in essence what we're doing is we're
loading an excel sheet into into our in
this case we're loading a Minitab and
foreign is a package that is probably
best to use to load other file types
including Minitab so that's one that a
lot of people like to use help read MTP
is Minitab portable worksheet I believe
it's the abbreviation and here we're
assigning my data equals read MTP that's
gonna that's gonna pull in whatever you
have it in Minitab and this is a way
that you can import text data that's in
an in a table so read dot table my data
dot text is an example there one thing
that I will say is the CSV that you'll
see that you see here read dot CSV that
is actually the the preferred way in my
opinion to load data into our if you
have data stored as as another file type
convert it into a CSV even if it's in
Excel and the reason is because our and
CSVs just tend to get along really well
they tend to have a lot less errors than
another file types of my experience the
three data type files that can be
exported from our again our table Excel
and CSV table of courses is exporting
data as a as a text file and you can see
that with it just a quick command
everything in ours is is the functions
are very simple so right table my data
comma and then your file path and you're
done once you have your data set
structured in are the way that you want
and you'd like to present that table to
someone a colleague coworker friend
teacher boss whatever it is this is the
command that you're going to use the
same thing is true with Excel s and n
CSV again my experience is that CSV
tends to work best but you'll if you if
you get into r and spend time with it
you'll of course work out what's what's
most comfortable and convenient for you
so write dot CSV my date file equals my
data dot CSV would be would be kind of
the preferred method for me
you